president Trump quickly condemned the
attack in Barcelona he tweeted that the
US will do whatever is necessary to help
earlier this week the president waited
two days to condemn a white supremacist
accused of plowing his car into a crowd
of protesters in Charlottesville
Virginia mr. Trump then blamed both
sides for that violence Margaret Brennan
is near the trump National Golf Club in
New Jersey as the president gets ready
for an important national security
meeting Margaret good morning good
morning well amid all that fallout chief
of staff general John Kelly will go with
President Trump to Camp David today and
try to focus in on what may be one of
the most consequential decisions of this
embattled young presidency will US
troops stay or go from Afghanistan we
are coming very close to a decision
today at Camp David defense secretary
James Madison the president's top
national security advisors will press
him to decide whether to add to or
withdraw the more than eight thousand US
troops in Afghanistan mr. Trump has made
clear his frustration with the war I
want to find out why we've been there
for 17 years last month the president
rejected a plan approved by his national
security team and began to consider an
idea from strategist Steve Bannon who
proposed sending over 5,000 private
contractors rather than US troops an
idea pitched by Blackwater founder Eric
Sprint's who recently spoke with CBS
this morning 16 years is enough we have
another trillion dollars in health care
costs that we're going to owe for the
Afghan war so let's bring it to a close
the president has avoided cameras in
recent days but he has not been silent
he swiftly condemned Thursday's
Barcelona attack
telling his Twitter followers to quote
study what General Pershing of the
United States did to terrorists reviving
a debunked legend about an American
general shooting Muslim soldiers in the
Philippines a story he resurrected from
the campaign trail shot each man with a
bullet that was covered with pig's blood
that type of incendiary rhetoric coupled
with the president's explosive and
delayed response to the Charlottesville
attack led members of his own party
including Tennessee senator bob Corker
to question his
leadership president has not yet been
able to demonstrate the stability nor
some of the competence that he needs to
demonstrate in order to be successful
now those are extraordinary remarks from
the typically circumspect senator corker
and Tim Scott of South Carolina
another Republican said the president's
moral authority has been compromised
Norah there was a lot of pressure from
the president's own party for him to
dramatically change course that's right
senator corker using the word radical
change market Brennan thank you so much